in certain cycles there are
always new hypes in the business world of the digital
world. in the past what online
marketing or seo didn't know exactly
how it works everyone wanted to
know the secrets there was so
much effort today it's nfc script that was meta
and for many years  nice and not
quite digital but also a bit is
the topic of cannabis what is
it all about when will it explode that
we are the big players what the
magic behind it is that he we looked
at talked to the three most relevant german
entrepreneurs in the cannabis
segment what understand  when it
exploded does it have to do with what us the
right exciting insights that you
need to know and that's coming now
philipp want nice that i can be here
anyway topic so a seventh
german
cannabis company on the stock exchange is still a
novelty how did it go at  you go on how did it
happen
i'll dig out a bit try
not to do it for so long i plan to
k  About seven years ago, a company was
founded, the solid mein group gmbh, where
we build food supplement brands
, and in 2008, due
to my personal interest in
this whole cannabinoid market, we took over a cd
brand from hemker, which was
still a very, very small e-commerce brand
with a few tens of thousands  turnover per month
and in the last few years they have expanded
the bryans into one of the largest online scbs
here in germany it's not
that easy to do online marketing for
cds but it's a different topic and
that just
lured christian angermayer onto my shoes and he
then came to me almost a year and a half
ago said hey let me do an
apprenticeship listed case this is
listed in düsseldorf bears the name
smartrac I definitely still want to do
something in this cannabinoid
market if I don’t want to get my
company fully involved  to give i was
made there to ceo and everything
you your le  last year about 14 months
from eroticism
came mostly from my pen he
has 13 companies we now have in
our group of companies and are very
well positioned for everything that comes
and they themselves also own
almost half of the company
but not half it  it's about a
quarter but i brought in
two companies i.e. two out of 13 compressed
i also had in this sector at the time
and in the meantime
a few have of course brought in
other shareholders have also come
through two capital increases and
christian held of course also a
larger one  part and it's still all very
familiar
but i have to say you're only
now in your early 30s or 31s, still exactly 31
and you're somehow up until it started
saying the dietary supplements play
2015 24 or 23 when
before that it was the developers so i
think  I didn't do a classical degree
at all, but I have n
I also
studied computer science but more for the love of
my mother because she said lars
does something clever where you can
get a certificate like that
and then
I actually did a
lot of work during
my studies  I looked it up when I was 18 and
then I founded my own software
company and I
submitted my topic to solid and
we then added to the
dietary supplements and
what I mean by that, it has also become
very wealthy on
paper  you can start in any case you can
see
i just mentioned and you have a part
right now that's great
is the company saying i
have the company are not yet profitable
in total there are parts of it with
us that are profitable
and accurate  as I said, this is a
huge growth market that still
lies ahead of us and I always
like to say this to all investors
this brand could not be profitable this year,
but what
good does it do for us? cbd thc is a huge
growth topic. all
these topics are
only really starting to be fun in germany/europe
and we would be there for a few more
years  really
stepping on the gas with the turnover you can also guess it from the outside
is not as big as
last year 15 million is still
let's say
manageable for the game
we want to play
the cannabis market or the cabin
rental market  in germany it's
generally not that big yet,
last year we think
we made sales of up to 180 million in the medical care market
over all over all the products aren't
us, they're the whole industry and the
cbd industry in germany is
n't really that much bigger either  yes,
the topic is super super new
and I'm pretty proud
of the 15 that we have and of
course the  be expanded even
further in the next few years, but if you
look at other comparable ventures in the industry, of course 15 still
very low, definitely what if we bought
a top product, so over all 53 now there
is what is
the core driver of these 15 million say
the core driver is still the civi the
brand handy still performs very well
online, always brings new customers to
our shop every day customer lifetime
value is huge because cbd we have been seeing that
for years now it really helps customers
, their life is somehow made
more relaxed, pain-free
and co
Of course, the
takeovers also resulted in some additional sales. Last year we were
allowed to take over or integrate the four companies from daniel kruse
.
one of them is kruse, the
industry
pioneer who actually started hans and cwd here in europe 25 years
ago and that comes
naturally  wholesale is still a
lot from the pc saves  e is
not that small anymore so the topic of medical
care until now this
year, especially in terms of
sales, will definitely stand on several legs
but within helpers what
is it then exactly so what do
people buy there is then oil or or  in the
end there are actually
mostly the classic cd oils 10 ml
bottles 30 ml surfaces
different percentage put 15 20
percent more meanwhile also a lot
of let me say functional cosmetics in
our store which are also sold very
well but it's exactly these
classic ones  that he also partially high
-dosed cbd oils that are bought by the customers
and then
consumed as they are called sublingual in technical jargon
, which means
that the drops are then placed under the tongue
because we can simply achieve
a great deal, i.e. a high
bioavailability  if the drops
are held in the mouth for as long as possible,
then if i swallow them immediately we will  also
have capsules in the range then
something like that has to go through
the stomach, of course, and unfortunately a lot of it goes
whistle and the customers next to a
few drops and try
to keep the drops in their mouth as long as possible and
then they experience their effects
I'll say it carefully but that's
not for repetition cbd is not the
element that makes you high that the thc that
's a separate topic
definitely so cpd is not a
psychoactive cannabinoid which is
still being discussed in the
industry right now cbd is now a food  ingredients
or not this whole discussion
has been going on for years now and will
definitely continue for another two years,
too, he has to be the board of directors we
have no facebook advertising we have
no google advertising the only thing
we can do is somehow google and
first seo and  affiliate marketing
and we positioned ourselves relatively quickly as one of
the largest philipp programs
in d  in the last two years that means it
's still why bitcoin 2012 yes that's
all still very very very very
shaky everything also somehow offline
distributions in the lh and in the pharmacy
is extremely difficult and it will
come to a time in the next few years
so that  then a bit simpler
and why is it forbidden to
advertise it as one that is yes now it
is eg also not legal in
our opinion cbd is marketable in food supplements in germany
and in europe
we
would actually have the last brand
actually that still  as a
dietary supplement
you are allowed to put your products on the market that's a huge
discussion yes we
could discuss
it for two hours now the core issue is that the food authorities
say cds new active ingredient
it didn't exist before and we say as
long as or since the hemp plant
the field says i come from the beautiful
allgäu there the farmer builds three kilometers  r
somehow removes the fact
that cbd is everywhere in the users and because we take it out
and then pack it in oil
doesn't mean that it's anything new and
that's this basic discussion that's going on
right now that will hopefully
be finally resolved in the next one to two years
and we can then simply
sell much better than
now when legalization was
discussed or announced from
a political point of view, your
stock price shot up immediately,
so within a few minutes or a
few hours it has almost
doubled what is doubled  right
, at that time we were the
only really tradable share
for the german market and we did a
lot of press work over the last year
we had to
catch up a bit there are two players who
have been on the market a bit longer
than us and  we were then immediately on
the radar of all the larger ones or just
generally of  all portals and it
caused or ensured that
the share price then
pumped itself up massively the free float of
our share is still relatively
manageable I say carefully and
that the two are I think we are
now at 15 20 percent free flow approx  and
the rest is still in the hands of
christian meier and those
who have joined us so far and
that will continue to spread over the next few
years.
when
i look at the number of shareholders, it's
gigantic, yes, what's happening there  is in the
last few months and that
all forms a very good basis to
continue building on it
is it a fair assessment to
say in the end cbd or not
legalization afterwards his direct
consumer company like many others
and have to time in the end
health or food beauty as
always product is in the end then is
selling and where does jet come from  zt so that
's probably or bitter
or not quite you have to know
contradict philipp it so we
now have 13 company is we have
three verticals in the symantec heat fools
the vertical two company is
one in canada the
insane ip in the drawer has where
we  also think in the direction of new chemical
entities so give me my
example the guys have
packed one our nervous system in de yes
like it is often done in the construction
sector and we calculate as so
-called super gladly used so
cannabinoids that much better on
our body  can have an effect such as
thc and everything that
can be found in nature in order to tackle future topics such as
ibuprofen and co and to build new solutions
for it
to are active in import
in storage in distribution and we
will also soon bring own  one medicine
brands out with thc so there are
extracts from the flower and co. what is just being sold in
pharmacies have now put together
a pharma sales team in a
joint venture with in
december so the pharma arm has it from
us yes it will be
clearly visible this year and  much larger
currently you can see a bit of cd
and helper mail but that's not just us at all
yes and with
this 13 fight because now of
course we also have a huge mastermind
together to think about how
legalization can look like how do
we position ourselves perfectly  for it or for that
means we are much more
than just the wellness director consumer
cvd brand company okay because the next
question was who where does this
famous excess return come from that you are always
looking for you don't just want a
five or ten percent
return now  with you with the courage that
the turnover must be more more
growth even more  return somehow
what you would otherwise have as you
normally would as another
player in the market sells a beauty
product there are already quite a
few that means you say that
it tends to develop in the area of research and i
the area of completely new active ingr
dients  you are just building
i think the mix makes it
ultimately yes on the one hand we have
this therefore this to consumer
arm on the other hand we have the medical
arm and in the future we will also have
this recreational arm and i mean
if you think it is only possible  a
few numbers on the internet and when you talk to
people about how big the
black market in germany is all
about cannabis and if we go into
legalization then we will of
course take the sales off the black
market yes and that means that i
also find the beauty of it  the symbolism of why
it is so much fun for me to
build up this group because we have such a wide range of
subjects because we are good at di  we
are versed in this whole cannabinoid
market for europe
and because we are actually very well
positioned everywhere, whichever way things
are going, it may be
that legalization will not come at all, everything will
remain at the pharma level,
then we are also optimally positioned there and
also have these waves of
defense part so i think the mixture
makes the answer to your question and
if the legalization comes that means
but then not only the cbd legalization would come
, which is already
talking a bit then you can also
legalize the thc so  he says it's made of
stuff that's familiar and then you
would also go in there because they also go in
legal and then also really
classic let's say
cannabis hashish always sell how
you do that how you recognize that grass because
what we that then
don't circle everything you just said,
so there are two exciting
business areas that are opening up  one
is the operation of the so-called
cannabis dispensaries or it
would be so you can't
compare them with the coffee shops in the
netherlands so there is a high probability that there will be no consumption on
site such topics will
certainly not take place but rather who
has ever had a dispensation in some way  in the
usa or canada knows that's super
small stores have great advice
so this concept we're working
on it very, very intensively right now
but we can't pack quite as much into the
podcast and the other
thing is the brands, yes, the brands
then in the stores we are working
very, very intensively behind the
scenes and that will
really be the flower, yes, the grass that
you know and can get from the dealer
around the corner in berlin, but there will also be
apples, extracts will be cool  be way
pence there are so many great forms of consumption
that are beautiful yes the elegance
is where i don't i b  in no
cigarette consumer, for example
not at all or very very very rarely and does
n't like burning, for
example yes for me there are
other forms of consumption and then it is important
to play the full range and
also offer everything that the customers want
to be able to and of course to be able to handle the supply chain
for it, so where
does all this come from where does
the thc come from where do the flowers come from and we
are already very well positioned today
because we are already doing this for the
pharmaceutical market and that
applies then  to be modified for the
leisure market
and that means if the legalization
really know what do you think what
sales can you make in the next
few years beginning when
would the legalization be through so
when did it become necessary
to answer the last question first
if  I spoke with all
my colleagues on the subject and
also with all the market companions, we
are in a cooperative relationship  iven
together
we all estimate something between one
and three years so it will
probably be in the middle then that will
be sometime in the middle of the end of 2023 yes there
are voices that say 24 there are
voices that say the end of this year which
I can’t imagine at all
because  we have to have a
narcotic
that is very tightly regulated, which every
pharmacist has to store in a safe-like
storage room like the other
narcotics, we also have to release
ingredients as leisure time
somehow, that means we still have to do a
lot together with politics
and you know that on the sales side  you as a talk
listed company i have to because we have to be
careful but the
black market is a billion
market i think we are all aware
if you look at where good
companies are in the usa and canada
we are talking about hundreds of
millions  turnover and exciting is
little time trouble if we do that in
german  schland manage well then
europe will follow suit they will
then very likely rely on the set of
rules that we
have to and are allowed to design right now and that
it will be a completely different game
in europe in the end you have to say
the bet is now placed by christian
angermayer  because markus is also in the
podcast the bed is not because of 23
million euros somehow and
conclusive market cap of which we
probably don't even think we'll be
asked at first
the whole thing really starts and then the
name of the company which now
somehow has 80 million market power  one of
the one billion merkel has
about 60 hopes exactly that's the
plan and then the
existing
business doesn't play the core role either,
but rather the preparations
are important for the moment iks when
things can get started, of course  in this
classic also thc driven market
probably just vie  l
grow a lot more than now with promises cd
active ingredients in other
products preparations are
pretty good because i have to
add is that the market for
medical cannabinoids is definitely
also growing strongly yes we
unfortunately still have it in germany
this stigmatization surrounding this
plant
doctors are still very cautious about
prescribing cannabis or should i
go for medical care nobis products these
are not growing year after year
quite as fast as
legalization would then i think that
would be the case  such a hockey stick topic,
but the medical market
will remain there anyway, it's
already relatively large, even if you look at
Europe or even worldwide,
so there will also be this medical
market and the
recreational market, it will exist at the same time
, but me  you're right,
everything we do today is the perfect
preparation for everything that will happen in the future  tig
may come and then
you only have these shops I
just said they rolled out
immediately, there was immediately somehow burned by you,
which then
somehow wrote on a video throughout Germany, the
climate and way,
yes, cannabis gives off 100 to the people
percent because we are working today
there is still no brand for but
maybe we will try that
over time because we still
have a bit of a dry spell ahead of
us we will reap something here and there from
what we are planning but  this is
definitely a topic that is very big on
my desk or very
second know and what are you looking
for companies to buy so already
bought for a lot how does this
logic fit the rheiner what what are you looking at then
we have a leg picture strategy that
means  we always look at where where
build something ourselves where could we start a
joint venture or where do we buy
something else and last year i  ch the
m&a activities are very much focused on
germany around da wo the same da
i mean i come here here is
also as far as the topic is concerned we
really are the leaders in europe unbelievable the
year 2017 started with the
legalization of medicinal cannabis
and this year we’ll see  us or
we are already looking very closely at
yucatán we are already looking very
closely at switzerland these are two countries or
two
areas in europe that are already very well
developed when it comes to cbd and it
’s more about that this year
maybe one or the other
to find european players but i also say quite
frankly and honestly it is not that
easy to find cannabinoid
companies that make sales north of 10 million
yes they are very very rare because the
market is generally still very
small and only in the next few  years is
really exploding and
we'll see what's complementary we
still have on the list
still not invested in kampen
the cultivations we have is
now the largest hand together
hemp cultivation company last
year took over the hand colors together
with daniel kruse alpha
to secure the supply chain there but we know the topic medical
until we are still looking at each other
very much  look closely it's
also worth investing
in to go a little deeper in the supply
chain back then you've been keeping
your hands off it
but what makes you so self-confident
that when this market really comes it'll
be a billion dollar market if you say
now somehow  all stoners all people were
interested in it but were
deterred because it was illegal everyone now
wants to get into this cannabis consumption then maybe it will
be really big as you say
then maybe completely
different players like really bigger fmcg companies will come along
and say okay  it's no
longer so popular selling next to it
j  oghurts or or now we're going
full throttle again in this area and
immediately roll out all your branding power into the existing branches with a lot of money
marketing spendings whole
topic then it's
just not possible for you because he has
so much cash
good question i'm so
self-confident because these big brands
are already knocking on my door and saying
let's do something together because the
exciting thing about this cannabinoid
market is that it's not that easy you
need a lot of know-how also
the licenses for such stores  it's going to
be incredibly complex to run
and through this group that we've built up
we simply have a
huge insight we already have
the experts on board who are
involved
and big big brands that i
don't want to name here today, with whom
we are  let's say we can already in the conversations
, so we'll bring
the power with us and you bring it
complete cannabinoid know-how of
cannabis know-how and let's do
something together here of course there will be
maybe one or the other big
player who will spread quickly
but i also like that
in this very difficult
market i'm also a  big block
chain fan and everything that is so complex
difficult where the where the entry was
also significantly higher i always find it
very exciting and that's also the cd
market so i'll give you a short example
all canadians and americans who also have
cbd without cbd  at the end of the day
unbelievable should
n't even be sold in europe because we are
only allowed to use cbd from eu hemp in europe
so there are also a few
berrys that you can't just overcome with a lot of
money so
stay within the legalization process
anyway  There
is a high probability that there are many regulatory provisions.
Yes, I can well imagine that
this l  licensing business is also
mainly given to Germans
because it will involve a lot of youth
protection, education and the like. I
don't think that any big
Canadian and American players
can simply flatten everything with a lot of money
and that's
just because I'm already very  much more
talkative i thought
the classic hand company that is that
just the canadian hand for all the
stock market listed in part or for the most
part a significantly higher market
cap but i would have even thought that
really classic fmc the companies
don't even now  coming from the neck area
we have been making yoghurts
something so okay if that's
somehow legal now if that's the next
growth market then let's go
into our industry logic we
've got ourselves we'll sell
ourselves a couple of tons and do something somewhere
we are already in other areas
now they are also buying fruit e  in or
or no idea exactly so with those
so I also meant when I
didn't mean with
the whole years canaria with them
we also talk but exactly with
other brands of which one would not have
thought that they would like to
have the pc  market
the kopts to us right now and that's also what
this fad was built for we are the
platform is a group of companies
a partner in industrial partners
who can support there but i
'm totally with diana there that will
give the big ones with
trying to squeeze a lot of money into it
but that also makes it exciting yes
now also spread yourself out over
the next two years until it
really starts working today with
you current group we have a
bit more than 150 people with you  there is a high
probability that it is distributed across all companies
and that
is a bit of the current setup, of
course, if we grow a lot,
ok  r
and have to exchange information with christel regularly i.e.
weekly monthly exactly
i am with christian regular
exchange times weekly times monthly
depending on who has how much running
desk is exactly and am also
very grateful to have him on our
side for the big questions also
someone  you can
see him pulling aside with advice and action
and that is very very
valuable
i hope you have a lot of what you can do for
cooperation also with
some testimonials celebrities rappers
similar what you can see that
life works quite well like that  co-
creation is that on what
apple has now
that means soon when it's
legal then not only capital branches
its own theses also its
own tact is possible
[laughter
] but it's exactly on such things that it's
your turn to talk to people with generis
multipliers us just right
because that's how we are i'm a
big fan of joint ventur too
we also founded a few
together last year with people saying yes
okay we are very good in this area
and we supply the complete cannabis
competent and that is also the
beauties of this group of companies
and is to
build up a group of companies that is also expensive in
accounting and collecting all the
data for the
stock market or nice stock market
and i had to make it worth
it somehow yes and that's why we're going to do a lot of
ventures this year cooperating
with others so that we're just perfectly
positioned for what's to come how
much ketchup  that's why we just did
we did the k again last year
but again seven
million grace as a
capitalist original capital increase we received
in december 19 we took almost
seven million once the
first capital increase and in
q4 again about seven million and
from  the seven million therefore au  I
still have a few things to
do and are now looking at what else we want to set up
this year
and whether that is enough for it. It is
very likely that not
only the owners of a stock exchange come up with the idea of
g new money and then saying to is
ue new shares  then you listen
to the media as a citizen of this company and
try again and again to find new investors
exactly there are different
ways that
we are looking at now or have been looking at for
quite a while capital increases bonds there are
different ways that you can
set someone up
but so far  the two capital increases were also
sold out fairly quickly that worked very well
because the topic is of course
also called super it was the first in
december 19 which was a bit
difficult because of course i
was allowed to explain the cbd to all institutional investors and now into it that is
not poisonous and not  quite so bad
and that's relaxed wen  n the topic
was a bit easier in his last year
and I think everyone who drew was
happy when the
course then moved in the right direction
and that of course forms a
great foundation for
thinking about where new new money comes from
and how much  do we really need it because
we have compared to other
market with two
currencies we will buy the share and we have cash
to be able to take over new company is meanwhile the
liquidity of the share is also much
better than half a year ago and that
yes everything forms pretty good ground
and waiting for it is a
lot because your focus on
normal retail investors, so to speak,
small investors normal people and how
much is on institutional investors
professional investors who manage money
i am glad that you are actually asking this
question because i have mine
Of course,
we messed around a lot with institutional institutions last year, yes  roadshows with
banks the usual topic but i
've been a
passionate blog chain user on a
private side for many years and also work here and there
myself and what i've
always found exciting in this world is
that all the projects
have their own communities  of the channel with
10,000 people in it, some of them
don't have to do any marketing at all because everyone
is somehow intensified by the token.
a brand
is getting better
stock exchange-listed company cisco
channel is open mayotte is also represented on tik
tok we will
find someone next week who will take the
complete five race sergej
to a new level for us
to simply build in the community and
also open a door  have for the
retail investor because i think we
both know the shareholder structure and
will s  in the future i will change neo
brokerjet republic scalable and so
on and so on but they do
n't have a chance to really hear lars müller
at a road show they
don't even come in
and that's why we're building a lot right now
exciting retail investor
relations concepts for these younger
investors or let me say the non-
institutional investors with all of them
you would be
much better here to make us better known in this
target group
and there is a lot that
we will deliver in the next few
months
I think he understood what he does
how you think about it also how that
bold you naturally come there and
we came into being is in christian
werth you have heard the podcast
several times yes so many
many thanks for the insight and
from a year of now  together he
tries to create a new market in
germany and in
the aftermath lauer puts a lot of gla  s
reference to a regular partner
here in the podcast, a la
die ko is a young company that is
trying to close the gap
between what e-commerce shops and retailers can
currently do and what
buyers often expect - it's often
about finding the right player  to have
for the customer before active shipping
communication track and trace a
digital amri tour portal all of this is
simply what customers expect many companies
can't afford it like that then
aleikum makes
sure that you make your fulfillment as a
dealer much easier if
you do it  handed over to aleikum and you can
escalate infinitely a very simple
control of the al-ko platform colleague
pripyat a few weeks ago in the podcast
of all sorts of co tells he also uses
it for his grand prix just like
many other the chick companies
including chocolate no wonder that
at mr reviews the rating of all
users far above the average for the industry
so the stars that are distributed there
are obviously much higher if
you want to know more everywhere aiko all
the information on the landing page
co.com mr now the second interview follows after
i thought where i would
like to invest myself if i
could i.e. thomas  station has convinced me very much
with his ford separates the
farmer for sure fun fact
why it is the farmer
going first will listen right away let's go thomas hey
you're in paderborn
right now i'm sitting in paderborn right now the weather
isn't that great but  yes right here in
my office better
internet line is now called in the company
there we just got the
fiber optic line but
unfortunately it is not connected yet
so i switched to the
home office here now how does someone
from paderborn get caught in the eye of the cannabis
hurricane  in germany it's a
good question so
ten years ago i and my buddy wilhelm had e  Founded a
company that is also very
successful and at some point it got
a bit boring for us from an
entrepreneurial perspective or the
business was good or repeated itself
well and then the thing
wanted to do something else
something with luxury food import
export and then just have it
looked at what's out there and then
we noticed oh man there was a change in the
law in 2017 and cannabis is
an interesting field I could
well imagine that's a very big
business field too and let
's just try it so it
really was like that  bit of an idea born for fun
but you don't have
any again now like with cannabis no
i am neither a
patient myself nor is it somehow clearly
recognizable cannabis was young the
school has so i know it
quite well but i
didn't have any business now
ambitions somehow to gain a foothold now that
has really worked out  I
surrendered and when he then realized
something could be done in the
field of cannabis how did you
start when you
had entrepreneurial experience and
probably need capital from the
previous company so how exactly are you still
allowed to do something they already have
so has a lot to get for it something
to slaughter 12 million so
you know it
works and there is something left
but happy seen and we state parliament
started to fill this gap
and say it was important that
we met with two other
friends of thorsten and  derek and
then it really was like that we
talked about everything like I said people with an
entrepreneurial background would be
interested in it is the trading business we
don’t need to make a big investment for the
time being because the direct one simply
said a hall man said
we can build anything in here  for you need
for production and so on and so f  place
and then we did a market analysis
and looked at how the
whole thing could work or how we
would do it and then
gradually started to work on it
and since, as it says, malawi zion are
wrong or love the challenge
, it was really an exciting
undertaking  where we all really had fun
or at the beginning we were there on our knees
and hands turned the floor into the
hall ourselves on the weekend and
finished hammering the turning point
then the office came and was amazed because of
course they asked right away
guys  your motto here now
sell cannabis and become a pharma you
also want to produce like that but you
have no pharma background at all they
say yes that is correct but we take
the matter really seriously i breathe
so i read a lot
about it and the first apps too
Written by yourself and
these are work instructions that you
have to do when you see the individual
steps in such a gmp
production facility, for example
lying how exactly is weighed what has to be
done with the coverings how how do you have
to weld them so all of these are things
that you have to prove for son gmp
guidelines that you are practically following good
manufacturing practice in your in
your company works and
accordingly you have to write a lot of
service operation procedures, so to
speak, and collect them all in a beautiful booklet and then you have
produced yourself then also means
cultivation or what as christian bauer
means not producing means for us
really we process the ovals into
finished ones  pharmacies but is it so that
we can be a pure dealer
in the business then you simply buy
a finished product from fonterra or
scam and sell it is just the
way you get decided in pharmacy
further we had the
ambition as dealers from the beginning  can be
exchanged relatively quickly or if you don't have a strong
brand b  don't you smoke the field in our
opinion not necessarily not
necessarily act and we
really wanted to establish our own
brand and that's only possible if you
can produce it yourself that means we
'll be able to buy goods soon that
's just big cannabis  sacks
if you want and they are then
really processed at our Paderborn site
, that means we first check them
in the laboratory to see whether everything is
right in terms of quality and purity,
if everything is right then we go into
production and then there is  just in
pharmacies sizes 5 grams ten grams 15
grams bags of different colors
and then the corresponding
flowers are packed that's you buy yourselves
the cannabis where where so far
mainly from canada a little something
from the netherlands so with
the netherlands we actually have
started that is or standard
product pedro can there are also quite a lot of
small dealers because that is relative  v
relaxed from the
regulatory from the effort that being allowed to
act we said
consciously we want to have our own brand we want to have our
own product that
means we want to bring our own train onto
the market and that's why we do
n't just have a high  c license but
also really a gmp license for all
relevant cannabis steps also
done because you have to understand 1
in the gmp area is a very large
area so it starts with the drying of
the plant then continues with
the cutting then it will be packaged and
so on  until it really ends up with the end
customer and you can partially certify yourself
for many of these individual
steps. many companies have also
done this because everyone in
the industry it was really a bit frustrating at the beginning
everyone said i can do everything
i have everything i don’t need cannabis
problem here when you asked for the
documentation or for the
permissions  de then very quiet and
then suddenly mum is ill or has
stomach flu everything
didn't work anymore that was the
initial challenge in the
industry but if you can certify yourself as i said
for a large chain of
gmp steps then
you should  you do that too because then
you really have a lot under control you
can produce goods yourself which we can
also do in life you can
release them you can dry and so
on and so forth so then you are
really flexible on the market
too because we just don't  we
were able to assess exactly how this
market was developing, that's why we
said we would definitely have our own brand,
but in terms of our service
portfolio, we also have to be very
large so that we
are really able to take all the relevant
steps at our
location, i have  So now I understood that I
bought it from
these well-known dealers
land one now but all the licenses all the
possibilities with you in the hall
but what do you do then specifically so
are smaller quantities packed believe is
worthless are smaller quantities
vacuum your the whole thing and then send it
out to the pharmacies by courier but that
’s it  but a classic dealer
function where that comes your own
brand so it means it's no longer there
behind the then just that is so and
we are just narcotics
area so it will really be yes
I know it is if you if you now
somehow  gummy bears for sale
pack a small one from a large bag
, i have both of them, but in the
narcotics sector it is really an
extremely big effort that you are
allowed to do that at all, so to
get this license you don’t just
fill in the slip
, it’s neat  money, time and effort involved
in getting permission from
the authorities to get cannabis from a large
bag  n to pack in small bags so
that you can also have free time independently, of
course everything goes shopping but somehow
to be understood economically is
still big bag small bag and
your own magic despite yes exactly and
your own brand is then somehow called
ford the company is called for twenty
natural  rachel for the reason that
we looked at the market at the beginning
and of course like every
entrepreneur first looks for some kind of us
peace it is difficult to find it in the cannabis
area at first
because you have the study stock that i would say is quite
poor
just not that much material
was now you can go to the doctor
and show them you this flower
works much better because then it will
be quite thin afterwards so
we looked at it and we noticed
everyone irradiated or almost all irradiated
their flowers makes some  points
and make sense from other points that
makes no sense because
any  bloom not only has
cannabinoids but also therapy
and the kills lasting with
radiation and also the tp names
enormous therapeutic effect and we
asked ourselves the story that is told in
germany at the grocery
store so if the
potato growers in germany then i'm not allowed to
irradiate it because it's food
why should I do it for medicine then,
as I said, it didn't make any sense for us of course
there are patients
whose immune system has started to take
effect they really
don't need dead flowers, so I
don't mean them either, but the wide range
masses are required, that's the form
and then we really started
not to buy from the big standard
suppliers, but we were
looking for a long time for a
supplier who could deliver us a flower of
perfect quality and also with
impunity, precisely because of
this, this  important tapping profile
and we are ni  not only able
to produce it ourselves, but our
coupe and the whole team is also
able to supply suppliers with gmp feeds,
which we say so nicely, that
means enabling suppliers from non-eu
countries to
be allowed to sell goods to us  because we also have
to prove it in the gmp certificate
and we did that with them
and when he had his
certificate we were of course able
to exclusively bring this variety onto the
market and had
tremendous success with it, so
last year we really had growth rates of
over  four percent in terms of profit and
sales and what we hear from the
forums and also from the pharmacies
, we were spot on with
our strategy as if we
now have to know that now we should also know that at the
moment but
ultimately we are planning around eight million euros in sales this
year  20 22 million stand for this
brand development and the signs for it
en also everyone is really on green it
is so that the market is also
continuously developing
these are all these blossoms story is just
the beginning we are now
entering the phase where more and more extracts
and and war commission
products come onto the market so to speak
we will then at some point when the market is
really completely emancipated then
also really see ready-made medicinal products based on
cannabinoids would be okay but
it means you are really pure farmer
from court sounds so first the club is
aligned to color right because
that's how it started the only
medical market on  been there at the beginning
now that the coalition has of course
said cannabis should be
legalized we are of course also committed to
recreation, i.e. to the amusement park, we have already
worked out various strategies
and then of course we also look for
suitable suppliers because
you get into completely different ones  quantities again
orson  do we already have to use up our
production capacities for the day
is so that we can really
set ourselves up well how can that be? there are
actually only so few who are active in
this area when i described my
first year like this how did you have a look at
2017  if you could found it like
that
thousands of people in germany will have done it like
every year they have asked themselves what can
you do to found a company then he ca
n't even come up with a no topic where you are
somehow not at all
could come up that's been around for years
so on everyone's lips also as a
growth market now there are still
only a few players in the end and you have it
when you hear it from 8 to over 20
million sales really now this
growth curve is full there so why
are there no longer who should do it now
is the miracle i apply so
this market is really highly regulated
that i can't say it any other way
i was really at the beginning  a
bit shocked and also frustrated
because of course I'm not used to it from the old way,
with any
regulatory hurdles to work with and
since really everyone I'm just saying stupid
foods and flint has to be approved has to
be certified has to be
qualified so you ca
n't just start  place a
vague order there and you know how to get
started but even for something as
banal as placing a vague order there
you really have to fill out a lot of slips
and someone has to come and give their
thick stamp otherwise no
country at all so you definitely need an
extremely
extreme  perseverance and
entrepreneurial perseverance in the market
because you get extremely frustrated you do
n't even have a nationwide uniform
legal situation, so each district
partially interprets the cannabis law
differently
he closes
the shop completely for her  if you somehow
it will at the beginning for example a
simple example radiate license years
we had traded pedro kahn
everything was released and then you got a letter
yes where is the radiate
ok everything is clear there you have to
apply until we get money again of course
done that christians
discreet 5000 per kind
and then it takes a few
weeks then you get it and then it starts
were at work suddenly a person saw
cool our district here he says he
can’t sell it on for as long as
i understand license is not
because two districts away he said i
don't care sell anything as long as
you have the license then you put it
on the table for me it's just interpreted
very very differently so
that as an entrepreneur you sometimes have a
little yes who is your biggest customer
our biggest customers are
various pharmacies, so we
now supply over a thousand
pharmacies here in the country  we have a
large sales team who also take good
care of you and they are really
exclusively pharmacies that of course
concentrates on 30 40 larger
pharmacies but and
the main ones who mainly buy
flowers buy something, so at the moment it is
still a very classic flower market
here in Germany  whereby as I said
now in the last few weeks months you
notice a bit in the direction of
extract the boss of the flowers is
then somehow called in what form
do you consume yourself as an end customer so
the most or but that is
classic is the vapor sighted or
smoked like that  is that possible
? just roll a joint or you have an
evaporator, for example both a cinema
you can put it on
top of it and that's a lot to tell us only about zenith
that's about thc but that's the
history of ccb so there's also
im  cbd market, which
is a bit
unregulated if you look closely, I would  claim
and we are now waiting for the
corresponding change in the
law so that we can
act accordingly, but
we are in the area of
ics law with
ur company, which means we ar
negotiating, we are negotiating and the thc p
oduct, so it's really impor
ant for me to understand that  unli
now lars müller or the
finns who are very active in the
cbd market also somehow
supplying end customers directly with oils and
of course just because they are not all kinds of
pleasure products or something but
always so for relaxation  with you
really also this
the skipper product cac because with all the advantages
and disadvantages of what you
sell a pharmacy so yes you
are all active in retail but that
is quite a different positioning it is
true different positioning i would of
course be aware of it now
call it a pine product so we really want to
talk about the whole story
bringing the whole topic more into focus because the plant is out when we
look at our body most of the receptors
that are running around there are in
cannabinoid receptors on every
important organ so we have
some affinity for this plant
and just because you kind of decided 80 90
years ago  has at a
european conference opiates are harder to
pack you can but
just get on it then it
will be ratified by germany at some point
and since then there has been neither great
research nor has the whole topic been pushed
further because of
various other lobby groups i
would like to say that is it  a
product that has potential has
to be analyzed and who knows
what else we can develop for medicine from this
plant so i find this
area really exciting we
also very consciously didn't when we built the
company we don't want to get
into  be pushed into a kippah corner
but e  it's clean is because we really work
according to the highest standards
in our company it's
really very important to us to be the
quality leader so that also means
that the topic of a society is
simply better received nevertheless you
have behaved with ford in your company
if I think so  already taken such a
loan this before it's a
bit like that also on the falkland side
walls here quite clearly we are
now also
describes where that comes from fortore wind
here is the old story that I
thought a few people thought the usa
there is somewhere  a super
cannabis plantation hidden somewhere and
we're on our way now and find it and then we made an
appointment somewhere on april
20th and backfired and that's how this name
came about it's the synonym
within the scene everyone knows
what it means  hats off different
backgrounds we we want to position ourselves as
a brand and of course
know  en we also know that at some point the
leisure market will come,
so we chose a brand that
actually works quite well in both worlds
, yes
it can work in leisure time
, i already admire the
sports clubs in paderborn at least
somehow and a little bit on well
to burn the brokers in a mainstream way now
she likes yes it was a bit
careful once more areas like one there
fourth after all they are
still narcotics but there are
no objections to company advertising
and of course we just wanted to have a look
it was like that  a kind of experiment when you
look at a football club what football is
the most normal thing in the world here
in germany we just wanted to place
a cannabis ad we
just tell you
where you have medicinal cannabis or where is it that completely
on the side gang that's the way it is  a
digital page is always displayed for a few
minutes and
we'd just have a look and we'd get a
shooter storm along the lines of the motto you
're stupid, what are you doing,
couldn't you do it or how is it
even received and after we did
that, we were extremely positively
surprised because the assumed
shitstorm was completely over
most of the people and that we the extremely ab
celebrated according to the motto it's really
about time that annoys me anyway everyone thinks that there's always
something negro dangerous here and
if you allow cigarettes and tobacco and
alcohol here then you have to
think about it too  speak and he got a very,
very, very positive response, but that's
what made it in the end, or the idea
that you ask more
people in pharmacies or at the doctors porte for the tried-and-tested thing,
no, we don't make it out of the
fact that we're people now
people all go to the doctor and sometimes need
a lot of cannabis we just want
to draw attention to the topic there is
such a thing ode  r you can
deal with it like with other things and
if you notice that it could be something for
you, then try it out, we
just want to show that it is something if
you deal with it like an
adult and maybe you can do it in
your everyday life  if you
want to use it medically and
really improve it and what can
I say now legalize the planitzer you expect what I think
what changes I mean that has now been
announced but
I'm assuming January 24 at the earliest
so had to for the first time and something like that
create a concept paper with
different groups drosten
social concept and so how can the
whole thing work the distances
do you need to train what is it only possible
through pharmacies or do you allow everyone
to sell cannabis to their business at a gas station you have
to endure everything first when things are going well
there are also a few deterrent
examples such as the netherlands
as  oh you shouldn't make a case
and when everything is up and
running then I
guess January 24th is the earliest I can start and
then it really starts then
so with the really starting the
porn we're not like that
region where something really starts as
always when when when the media
write hotly about something there you come with
such a short click but the
market is actually developing
continuously our constantly further so
it will be clear in the first three four
weeks there will definitely be long queues from
coffee shops or forfour  pharmacies or
dispensation depending on what the concept
looks like, of course you will always be of
course that is the
declared goal that in the leisure sector
if you definitely go in the way
we have already had a lot of
talks with potential partners
in the direction of that  we definitely
don't do that with starbucks and stuff like that
with star wars of course not nei  n
So as I said, it's also
really important with the whole leisure
story that you make sure that
the staff in the sales
outlets are trained accordingly because, like alcohol, it's also a narcotic.
That's something that definitely affects your body
and it can't do it now
just say here we grab we always do
what you want so come you need
adequate advice no matter ever gets to the
man and that first has to establish everything
working and then
we work with different people on
different concepts yes okay and
I would take a look at what you  happening in the market
like a find with the
citigroup the money is already locked in here
somehow yes the burden of the
german stock market
is listed that now remains over you that
there are four of you doing it or or coming or
probably less regularly people
who definitely talk that we evaluate
in the last six months, an
extremely large number of calls from the to  all the
talks we were really surprised how
many companies in
the world know us and would like to do something together with
us and will do that the market
usually consolidates
whenever it somehow grows together
due to the wide range
we will definitely have a look  the
future will bring us like this and
maybe one or the other will then work
together yes i can well imagine doing
a capital increase
that would be exactly that so now
wants to build up a different company, for example the strategy around
how we collect money and  then make
a strong brand in the cbd area for that
you also need a lot of money at the beginning as they
just went into the retail
area we had the
strategy we start with
medical first try the topic of sourcing
and get the whole regulatory
grip lars  has the concept of the
pack and then buys the appropriate
players to d  Ann a corresponding
platform for form is all
different approaches with
their advantages and disadvantages and we have
decided to go this way but as
I said in the future especially in the
retail sector we know more
more power and more money from it so that we can also
compensate for the time there will be
we definitely investors it's
better to do that i mean you couldn't
be what level from 8 to 22 with
sales growth profitable then
somehow in 23 then maybe in
50 million sales somehow also than so
you could somehow
theoretically even now from the
let the cash flow continue with the focus on
medicine then you
don't have to do anything at all or is it simply the
temptation to take this large
legalized retail market
with you is too great yes the temptation
is definitely too great that
's important for us as entrepreneurs the absolute
hit  right now I ca
n't say anything else because you're on a  at the beginning of
a whole new market so it's
just not there yet i feel a
bit like with the wild west so
now you can stake a claim
let's see what happens
so we should be
totally keen on the adventure that's why we will
too  but as
I said, you need to set up 30 lives in the retail sector from your own
cash flow. You
can build and finance it
that
has already been proven and somehow
even got this far several times now
i think classic ones like
you are not allowed to invest at all
then i am not sure not all of them
so you have a lot of institutional
funds this is not allowed some
private family offices or what
you can say it is that you don't want to have anything more to
do but there are enough ideas in
the fin industry  and if
every user were
interested now, what is not only
currently worth, because I'm
assuming several million
here, who isn't here now, so we
're very, very classic, proven,
I'll say we have eight
million euros ebit  done he chatter made
8 million euros in sales and
more than a million ebit you have to see
in the negotiation what that is
then worth but not hundreds of millions
now but also no longer c
is open will miss and who are
you up there doggedly that you  can
always get in touch with us i'm open
for ever everything has shown me more and more life
is the best strategy
talks to everyone i chat with
every listener for a long time and
see if you can somehow make something out of it
yes she did  deceived this
this attitude if the market
is now legalized that's
a bit before me then there aren't
that many
I also drove foreign players into the market where
they say okay they we have that
kind of power already leads others already discussing structures also different experiences provide other sources with economies of scale at every corner they then somehow overrun this market here
can of course happen
we can already see when you look at
some cap tables how strong, for
example, alcohol or tobacco and how they
are pushing onto the market that
food giants will also drink with it
when it becomes legal so that can
and will definitely happen
you just have to look  How you position yourself beforehand
, as I said
, it has an advantage that you were able to learn the medical
field and gain a lot of
experience and if
you then put it together into a good
concept, I'm sure
that you can now hold your own against the
big ones  can because one day I would also like to
push behind it  In
other words, the cannabis market as such should be
the cannabis consumer that
doesn’t necessarily work now
again as a classic consumer and and there
is a lot of
transparency in many UK people who also need a
lot of contact with customers
and let’s see whether it’s always large
corporations with relatively sluggish
structures  can depict and deliver
, or whether smaller,
faster players aren't better at
getting the goods to the
customer and as I said next to the
competition and see what's happening
and in the medical field I think that
's lucrative on its own only
now I just had  kinda cut
short relatively few pharmacies
so far the work will be there are
probably thousands
or tens of thousands more of
pharmacies in germany yes almost 20,000 pharmacies
in fact yes but even with the
pharmacies the topic is not everywhere
now since it is introducing cannabis  is
now there ten people come every day
your a  in the pharmacy and have
cannabis prescriptions at hand that also
the prescription scorte or points they
are already relatively selected here in
Germany and for the pharmacy it
doesn't make any sense to
stock up on cannabis because yes
it doesn't matter now  but
i think it will gradually increase because
the acceptance in the medical
field you can already tell, that's
why it's concentrated on
1000 1500 pharmacies that
i've been dealing with the business for a long time
okay okay i don't think i understood
it roughly how it works  should
or even that he is doing so
if
plaintiff exciting because you can be
sure so i will give you letter and
seal so if this is legalized you
are in 10 15 years have exactly the same
experiences as both of them for example
with crying the wine travel has it
Will cannabis travel? You will
taste different straits. There
will be cannabis-based events  n
recently in amsterdam at an event where the
cooking was really at the highest star
level, all the dishes were
somehow made with cannabis oils and that
was extremely funny and also very
tasty, so this lifestyle
area in particular will be used there a lot will happen
and yes it will be an exciting one  time okay
okay
exciting so
it will definitely be sand today like
the one in the next
and maybe yes we will talk now
and you are you to say
that was already very successful
entrepreneur but maybe in three four
years then like a superstar
entrepreneur of the
offensive unbelievable rocket  it was
all right i keep my fingers crossed wish
you lots of time thank
you dear philipp and we'll keep in
touch and who knows then we'll
start the next podcast there was
then standing as a junior
who knows who knows that's over  lots of
love greetings to
everyone who is following me in any way,
hopefully have noticed that on the
seventeenth and eighteenth  time our
festival returns to hamburg in the
city in the exhibition halls and there a
knife has a special stand
, namely that of iwc schaffhausen there
are even parts threatens like the big
parts tour of iwc one of the iconic
models of iwc you can then
have the situation explained how the watch works in
detail you can experience the brand
shows interactively there is a master
class is deep insights into
watchmaking as well as luxury goods
marketing and industry you know
iwc one of the most attractive watch brands in the
world in precision work manufactured in
schaffhausen for yourself  place in
scheffau great seen how they
do it a lot of passion i
think it could be really cool
always standing on the watch interested in
something like that and festivals where you can
come by otherwise there is of
course all the information about all the models under
the toilet point
and finally the biggest one  name in the game
meanwhile almost 70 million already
Funding collected for his ski club,
a well-known German entrepreneur figure,
by the way, with a cdu past and now that
we
made an episode a few years ago, he is welcome again,
fina teased
higher in it, so if
you want to hear the whole episode with you, give it a
go  career you have to say you
've already
gone a long way in the whole digital
tears you've even been to the
local politicians in the cdu i think of course
we yes what's up with cannabis is
surprising i once
noticed
native kieler or even facebook
none board member
and now you are navi four years are
now that you have this attribute
so it makes three years short and even back
then in the first year i think i
spoke to myself exactly because there are a
lot of interesting things with you so not just the
career of the
cdu  man to the cannabis company so
then also the investor base the new
model why do you have it  you were looking for cannabis back then
so that's why you could be looking for it back then that
was a very important story
you just told me I definitely have
roots in the cdu and as a
teenager as chairman of the young
union I actually
fought for legalization back then in
flensburg in schleswig-holstein
2001/  2002 because the climate here bothered
me for various
private reasons there was a therapy case
in my circle of friends and
that's why I was busy with it
was of course a lost battle at the time
2003 in the cdu there is
legalization there I
still have a lot to fight for  used for this and
when the federal government allowed medical
cannabis in Germany in 2017,
the point was reached for me where
I thought now I can torture how
controversial the
faction linked this topic with what I
think I’m good at, namely
companies  build up and that's how
it really is  For me it was an absolute
heartfelt topic and founding 2800
was actually exactly the reason
why we said the topic was going to be someone at
the time because it was just a
matter of retirement for and were and
then everything progressed quickly
at least if you read this communication
then it worked  go on what kind of
already got a few million at the start
also from prominent people
somehow in the middle of last year 35
million you get that really a lot of
money a company what you are doing now is
currently so worth while
in any case in the good three-digit
million amount what the what the
destination
we won't talk about the exact numbers, but we'll move in that
area, ok, and how big the
company is in terms of employees
, or if we have just over 100
people, we now have two
locations, one in berlin has
our headquarters there  I would
say we are around 80 90
then we have no  ch one two locations in
frankfurt that is the production there
are probably around
ten people there and then we also have
pharmacies
field service key account managers spread out in germany and so
on so overall i think so and
will be the current one and what the model
well, we have already learned how models can work in
other episodes here in the podcast
,
so there are a wide variety of revenue models,
how to try it a little bit
, well, we're actually okay, two
different go-to-market paths, we
have the whole medical area
cannabis speaks the doctor prescribes
the patient for thc products
even very often in the area of
herapy, for example, but also in th
area of falli
ep in the area of chemotherap
e area of multiple sclerosis there are var
ous indications of how cannabis can actual
y work there the doctor prescr
bes the patient the patient goe
to  r
apothecary löws prescription and get
a high probability of our
products so this is actually one of
our redeemed would be i would say almost
50 percent of the turnover at the moment the 51
percent is more so that you know each other on
the consumer goods e-commerce whose
shares the cpd products  under the
brand at and also now this brand
displays actual consumer products
that stand in the way as well as being sold in
dominant e-commerce and
there the regulation is of course
relatively free there anyone can simply
buy there you don't need a
prescription that means these two  areas
well billen and medical
these are basically our core areas making sales today
and we also have a third
revenue model that's basically our
production but it's basically just
fresh price in the short term right now and
it will probably
take a while until the whole
position is implemented  in fallen cultivation he
fed the ext  reaction that
means you have the cultivation of cannabis that
you experience because it has a so-called
biomass and in the
end other products not only
come from the biomass but also
extracts, i.e. oils, for example both
medicinally and in the field of advertising
and in the end, like the oils, they are also the
basic requirement for everything else that
comes from the plant in england and
accordingly our
production is the conversion of
real biomass so blossom
grabbed you in the end and that’s how the biomass comes where
costs like a yes and now
Most of the idea came from German organic farmers,
so it was almost an industry at
Sunpower, that can be any farmer in
Germany, so we have
a network on land, so to speak, for the
area of medical channel is where it is also for thc,
e just have diffe
ent providers both in  denm
as well as spain portugal has
now runs out of south africa that one has sort of
like that  the countries where
thc is also grown where we
can continue to process it in frankfurt but i have
learned words a lot of licenses it is
not so easy to be allowed to do something like that at
all and so you know that it is
an absolute nightmare for the state but
i can tell you  say you're
usually used to
reacting very flexibly to working very
quickly making spontaneous decisions
and in the end also who can afford to stick to a short time
so soon
everything will come into play take longer that you
actually have a challenge
that you didn't foresee  speaks
she needs a narcotics license
for the theater topic you need an
import license needs migros does it have the
csu needs you to have a manufacturer license
you need one is allowed so there
are probably probably 578
elli dances that you end up needing for everyone we
do so you stop  can't go to
the market and something for every
new product  you put it on the market
the whole game starts all
over again so new ones are always being
qualified and so on you can’t
just change the manufacturer that easily if you’re
now manufacturer because they have to be requalified
again and again that
means it’s possible
administrative eyebrows and
where does the turnover lead in the end so how
much is there currently at why
over the two activities so
the waves like in products with cd
and the medical products yes we were aiming for sales in the
double-digit
millions for last year
We'll see how things have developed in the last few days
, but I'll say we're
probably just under 10 million
with sales last
year and that we were
able to almost double this plan last year,
so the medical business is
looking at you because of the licenses  walked later than
we thought that we also the
gru  nd why diocese sales were a
bit behind there the cbd
business went exactly as expected but
we originally
thought last year we will make 50
sales in the future if you see it is
probably 60% to 70% of the almost ten
million at the end
cbd and
30 to 40 percent at the end of medicine
is unbelievable now, but in January,
for example, we look at the
volatility, what time delay that
then occurs, so the piece on
both levels, but it's also the case
that in the end, the whole
company evaluation, the whole structure
now  don't you make sales for ten
or 20 million so
exciting it's so crass
you have to achieve bigger and
bigger goals when you have your rating
and also such investors then he wanted
to build with several hundred million sales in the middle of the company
and that will
probably be in the next  year only if
there is now legalization and you
then also like yourself, so to speak  a
private customer can honestly deliver a few fires in the tires just like
others
so what we still have of course
is not mentioned at all but
minimal area mistress a
ready-to-use drug we were
also in the press that endo
holidays mean that it actually
means again  blockbuster potential because it can
be cannabis based on drugs
against schizophrenia if it is
successful phase 3 that is of
course another huge opportunity
and values for the future but you are of cours
right if you ignor
it that is of course legal
zation  the time when most of the
imagination is behind it the medical
market next the cd market is also growing
but legalization is of course the
blockbuster event what then of course comes
again the need
probably multiplies a hundredfold overnight
when it comes to work and that
is of course again  the thing on the
world while preparing wo wi  r
look very closely what can we already
do today to be fit there how does that fit in with
this division of the company how else
would I think it would be good if
we just set up a medical
station and all the licenses from - good at the
same time we have them in the consumer
sector  brands are built and of
course you can combine that nicely in the event of legalization
, that means we have
the consumer brands but they also
remain and the
licenses mean that we see ourselves
as well prepared today, but of course it will
also be exciting
again  will happen then you think you
want the legalization to come about
my what will you do i've been no
politics for a relatively long time on the road
again and again as a hobby and not not
firmly but i know the cemeteries
a bit so the people who believe
burden six months will now
praise  buy cannabis market
i think you have to disappoint
my  the hypothesis is that it will now take a
year know the
legislative
process is actually complete then it will when the law is more
or less ready then
parliament will go then there will probably be
a few creative implementation scenes
i assume that we will have the first
legal cannabis in one of the  donor
or pharmacy in Germany
that can be 23,000 but that's
not so far away he knows exactly yes there
is not you the chance then
learns relatively quickly even if we
scale correctly this time yes total
but we have to prepare well for that today
because just because we are
already playing in the telemark channel
doesn't mean that we are automatically
in the political arena in the
regulated market and that's really
what we're working on with very strong strong
points says a little
something about your various investors,
so you  have the described works
but you have an investor base
kling  t a bit like the rome air
festival well
[laughter]
i would also like to have it but then
emi mario götze klaas heufer-umlauf stefan
die giesinger ulla yes
what makes you bring everyone in what does it
do you also get something for them
maybe  also earns interest how did it
come about so i think we
were very affected right from the start is
that we were investors colors that
also give good success yes and by
that i mean that the market is
really okay the guys are serious
it is a good company  Solid
people come in and we started
with the classic German ran,
from holtzbrinck ventures to cherry
ventures to atlantic labs,
bitburger invests and so on
, so of course we already have the
focus on the a lot of business because of
course those  are they
also the main part of the money in the end
why did we touch deeply on the
level i think on the one hand about can  to get nabis out of the shabby corner
to say look if
middle east canada invests determine
it can't be at all but of course what
we have done we have very strong
looks he is if i take any of
the size free if you really
very positive  who also have a belief in
the connection to the
issue as a topic, i mean von klaas heufer circulation is
not the huge year andré schürrle
mario götze dennis aogo everyone has their
personal points of contact, especially the
athletes are very strong with cbd and there
are also various studies that
already  show that cbd can also help in sports
there is inflammation in
the muscles white both generations
that means each of these investors
had a point of contact you
can imagine only there also very special with
with cannabis that shouldn’t come as
a surprise to anyone and in the end of
course we have  already asked not only
what bring so what bring money
then put names on the table but that way
you can help and of
course we have had some great
experiences with the strategy things,
for example, have now released a
product that is now
exclusive to dm they had a brand there
called new and there  we have now created a
culture of cooperation with and
new weight limit cpd that means we just have to
look not just
to take the investors on board
because
looking can help you where can we leverage synergies and what can we do
together and for  example
climate last year he didn't
grow on a field in team to the land
for us what is working now will be
products again that was a nice
story because first we're at the piano
in then stay finance country that means of
course we've always looked at how
do the investors also suit us and
we don't just want to insist on the crafter, we actually want it
with
all ten levels the investors that we
have then i regularly bring together for a
period of time so now be somewhere
with it munich somehow knows with the
government so actually it's
not just the thing where we say we put the logo
on it you can see the hall
but we also work  already very
active with our are climatic that is
a lasting tradition so or
is it once is once again unique you know in
the world want to
test that now as I said with
the unplugged it also used very well
on its visitors to the climate  into the country that
was first of all i would say hold the
pilot phase that we have now this
year for example do
n't do it for now but for example if
at some point it can be completely legalized
and you can also grow everything normally in germany
as a farmer which
cem özdemir  has already indicated then of
course it can even if the chain
finds the right climate at some point
nabis adds yes there is has the
cliffs kliemann color edition is so
there there is definitely a lot of
imagination in there apropos finn klima
is jahn's friend gmr and i
somehow suffered a bit
with him or or thought of you of
course when i did  recently in an about
man
yes what was
there there was such a cannabis episode and
there were both of them and me you were
prominently in it that was probably
not a particularly nice evening
for you you well let me do it but
a perspective that mine  the best
sales figures had that because of
course a lot of people
seemed interested enough in
the contribution to try out the topic, which I found very
nice on the other hand, of
course, I wasn't now had
different reasons for the contribution with the contribution
now put cbd in the direction of
homeopathy, which he had repeatedly
indicated, while tebe has
the stu  Seriously he asked me if there was
a medicine for the idea cash
there had said one position that's
only one thing there that keeps
citing the reason why cbd is not effective
can now
somehow not fit personally because it's definitely I
mean a ready-made medicine
does that mean effectiveness is
that the question of what dosage is
paralyzed there are many smaller
studies of course nothing
conclusive that's why we
don't make any health claims on the products
but that has to be completely dismissed as
useless products he now found a
a bit more honest, so
I keep making you more expensive and I think the point
I had to do again was
that the products in the end
customer area are very expensive
and
I think that was a bit of
a nuisance that says okay, yes,
the effect  is unclear at least and
for that is a super expensive that was a
bit points the price is a t
I mean we've actually been trying
to reduce it regularly for three years. You have
a problem with piding and
unfortunately that's just the way
it is. Of course you have the problem that
all the potent plants that also have a lot of
cbd that you
could extract cheaply that we in Frankfurt
unfortunately we
all have thc inside, that means you ca
n't just grow
it in germany, that means if you want to
take plants that are grown in bulk in germany
, then you have to use the so-called
industry or the users,
but there you have it  sometimes the flowers
only contain three percent cbd, which means there
is an incredibly inefficient
production at the end of the day and that is of
course one thing that makes it very
expensive unfortunately so i gave an
example at that time kilo kilo twd
coffee actually up to 10,000  euros depending
on where you get it if you get it
with high quality like we do
then of course you can  be so expensive
and you can of course calculate back
what is left with such small
products and people always think
that we have a margin of more than 90 percent and
the products in europe are
stuffing the money in our pockets so
they don't eat them  i think our margin
is lower than that of the
consumer product because
the production and the
raw material is really very expensive and i
think that in the end it
should be interpreted as a kind of intention that you end up paying a high price for a
product that doesn't seem to be fully
effective  it
's actually more or less the idea is how
you want to earn money with
it i had that i don't know now
really fervently back because it's
just not like that because on the one
hand there's the study on the
other hand the product is just because
the raw material is so expensive and in
the end the margin is not as big as
you would think and accordingly
wi  e said that I wrote the contribution the
shame because I don't think it was
100 percent well researched okay
okay but it brought me to us when you came to
us and also the high prices
for that apparently accepted by many
people so for you it's the
first time  not so bad at all
yes we can also say we do that
is year after year increase the
lower our prices also fall year
by year so by people for the third year in a
row makes that we have also
lowered our prices it will
continue like this because all the more  more people
consume the more volume is
grown in the end, the better the
economies of scale and the cheaper products that
are not at all cheaper at the end of the day,
yes, then we will definitely do
that, so that for the margin that
we also have to the customer
give back and I think that
's very fair but as I said you can
make people right how did you do
business all over Amer
to get ican investors so i understand
with the germans if then that
's still a relatively tight network
if you first know a few of them
then you know the others inside
the götze knows the student and so that
's that you can imagine
yes and I think the cherry and many
of the Wessis it's all kind of
a German investor business
mafia almost kind of but but
suddenly we have I mean I know
that you not only have the flight but
you also got me a scooter brown
justin bieber's manager first over the net
and who basically invented it so
how it so who is there with
you the network what he invested in the end the
other yes so the scooter
brown because he is one of our core
investors entirely  well knows in the chain
from young von terry ventures very well that
means there were points of
contact relatively early on that was great to
have  we just had the first
contacts of the us label because
at some point an ex-manager of
universe and music finally made a ticket with us
relatively early on, he had more
or less and the presented one was immediately on fire
and once
you have a good brown and a good brown  then it's
a bit like in Germany people talk about
it then suddenly others come
around the corner and what we made really
difficult then but
to see selectively who actually
suits us and we almost don't do it
just to pass level deep the pharmacies
bord cannabis cool you can
make money and here's my money that
just wasn't enough for
us we really wanted that there was also a
certain kind of commitment behind it
we will also be
launching products together in mülheim this
year speaks for itself that's fine  very important
but as already said that is at the
end of the consumer as walther is there first and word gets
around  and
asterisks invested and the one that was
invested then comes the third and
then again reinforced with the message
so you sometimes have the
network effects that are very positive
and the pr also works very
well i saw it even in the new
york times you are with one  city is exact
y so the americans look can of cours
be very interested in the germa
market that's just so un
erestimated you always like to talk about
legalization the two a
d the only country through dollars or th
only two countries that are not c
mpletely legal worldwide at th
moment  canada and even the usa
are just a patchwork just so
california has legalized has legalized new
jersey text again not
that does not mean at the
state level that you can no longer
underestimate germany will throw in
a legalization of the world's largest
cannabis market point yes  85
million inhabitants by far the largest
more  inhabitants as canada and
california together and accordingly
for all the americans
who are basically already interested in the
market is of course
germany if you want it that way you next
big thing and that means they look
very strongly over and they talk
and that’s me  companies
like
the new york times are of course also a bit proud of it and tell us
eat a lot because now the leading
companies that will be behind it
because now the big champions in
europe that are at stake and
accordingly i was of course very
proud are the new  york times who chose
proactively and also because they have
the feeling that we are so beautiful and
don't just belong in germany or on
the continent and that of course
you would have a nice reward for the
work you do and accordingly the
times also has articles on it  in the
fourth round and we
actually had a lot in in afterwards  bound
inches lasts the usa and there
will soon be situations again where
we naturally still have a large part of
the money mentioned by him on the
account, which means we
have no pressure at all for the time being, although I
have collected the money, there is still
talk of legalization  so we have
already budgeted
for the money now living quali to put the money into the renovation
that was mainly for the
medical expansion that we
thought the international expansion
i am of course with the legalization
suddenly a completely different business case
that man could finance and there
let's all think about whether the
resources are either circumvented internally
and say, well, you take a part
of the money is now accumulated for
the medical expansion and packed a
little something in recreational or
alternatively you actually do a completely
normal round of just the whole how
cross-section to
fire them if you want  that to
prepare and there we are
graphics cards so as I said we are
honest and punk rating still have enough
money but of course you always think
23 years in advance thinks that's what
you could do today if you had money
and the thoughts make advertises
was yes for  the bcc part the customers are
currently most ago so it's in the
window marketing everyone whatever
you did he showed a few post
or or you what is it probably coming
verdi customer so that's similar we have
actually we don't need a
secret either  this causes difficulties
in online marketing for the big
media groups that google and facebook,
which can't allow a bit of any
form of advertising, the same also applies to
some extent with display networks and so
on, that means we always have
a bit of a
struggle there, so there's always a bit of
april
accordingly  i have to say that
today we actually have two or three
large customer acquisition
channels  It's clear where you say there are a
lot of people who just google and
that's not advertising, it's more or
less organic, say the
run-up ball then the second topic where
we I think are very much in
free fall as you said and  The
third thing is what I call it in a
broader sense, cooperation, which means a lot of
money is also a big topic for us,
but actually when I went into
my e-commerce historian now at
rocket internet, other
companies were also there, of course, always has google and
facebook  combined almost 50
percent of the turnover and the rest was
then somehow through various
channels with each other and we
had prosiebensat 1 in it also
have a lot and very successfully via tv
but unfortunately and that's the topic it's
still a shame that you have all these
traditional  can't
use online channels like that but that's why you have to
be creative and come up with other
things what's your be  best-selling
product in this area, i.e. in the consumer area,
which are products for sleep products, i.e.
everything that hits, both
the capsules and the displays of these are
also excellent, also in the mps and
over 80, so really very high
customer satisfaction, we always have
great feedback from customers
Unfortunately, we are not allowed to
publish them because that would then be the law on the
advertising of medicinal products, but in
fact there is a really blatant
fan base of the sleep products,
in addition to the
classic cdu, because there is a
large group of people who
really help and are really there
goes to exchange and on the third the
third product the category
probably actually the world
kaiser which also actually has one of
the great popularity we will also
have to adapt again to become more
sustainable we
still have a few challenges
but that's I think  the three  large
product category and in the medical
field what's what's coming
yes probably we also have
different
products in the medical field so once the normal
cannabis blossoms so what you
can just imagine that
looks to us again the broad is next to the
extracts the third value finished
medicinal product or  or or
drugs dronabinol which
are more or less the active ingredient so the high trt flower
is by far the best-selling
product you followed the extracts okay
i think i think
so the last question
maybe that’s a bit turkish
too, so to speak, to persuade the doctors
to  your medication or what happened at the end
of the period do you recommend
that the patient then go to the pharmacy
and after you ask is there actually a
measure taken then the
classic pharmaceutical representatives and things like that
actually happen so we have a team against
other people who go to the doctors on
principle  is under  the patient
can ask the pharmacy for a
special product about which
the doctor has to prescribe it so it wo
n’t be so that the doctor
can say cannabis is made here and the pharmacist and
the patient decide together what
kind of canada there is a wide variety of types
so as i said  high thc lowest
thc calls film idea low cbd balance is
easy in it that means in the end it is the
one who prescribes a product based on
his experience his conscience our
best knowledge in the end
and that gets the
pharmacy as a prescription to keep the
patient and the patient  if the
pharmacy says they don't have the product, for example,
then the doctor and the pharmacist can of
course exchange it for another after a short phone call.
the product can be that
but it's not that simple
but we also experience a few with
our key account managers
times like this use
talking stop regularly with doctors
and visit them on site explaining
the advantages as a therapy can
explain the advantages of our work
products and accordingly is that
every business model that we have about the
doctor who then ultimately
trusts and has our product is a
good one  product of the associations prescribes
so that's the technology of the classic
pharma set up there
okay okay well i think the update is
it's clear here's a bit on
the lookout what's the blockbuster
then it's coming here before
you already made it worth mentioning
sales figures without legalization but
like since up to the new york times everyone is
waiting for what will happen the market is
huge that i am not so sure
that germany is the global
market watch but it will be all the more
exciting we will keep our fingers crossed and i am
sure then  there will probably be here soon
if you feel like it you
have time that that  next update we will be
happy to talk as soon as the trained on it
starts with the legalization
we can talk really
happy all right
that was our cannabis triple if
you think we should
invite different guests to a topic more often and are a topic
because that's how we write illuminating  I'm happy
with links or with installed
I'm happy but feedback then we'll build
more often soon according to not
just a guest means three times to look at what's going
on like gets a lot for it and
until will also trigger warning in this
podcast will be topics like war and
flight  treated
when bassam sleeps then he sleeps
but really
because of some noise he
doesn't
open up because of a lot of noise not
even that night when
32 bombs fell from his village within a minute and a half
i was also sleeping there where exactly
next to our family house there was also a
bomb i think even
that day it was  r very funny so very
bad but very funny situation i
didn't change to the true
story of a young
syrian fleeing the civil war in his
home country
[music]
then it really started i knew everything
that had to do with violence or
tried it in syria
across the mediterranean sea it was very
crowded it was still possible that was
the
worst we will have experienced in travel almost there really
until a new life in
germany i once after
i think it was two to one and a half months the
other way around didn't dare on the train
get in alone
what now listen to his story
[music]
everywhere there is podcast
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr